[Musique]
nous recevons ce matin rock Olivier
Mestre bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes président de LARCOM l'Autorité
de régulation de la communication
audiovisuelle et numérique ex CSA
aujourd'hui et demain se tient à
l'Unesco la conférence du reframe il
s'agit du réseau francophone des
régulateurs des médias il comprend 30
membres issus de trois continents Europe
Afrique et Amérique du Nord le réframe
dont d'ailleurs vous allez prendre la
présidence pendant deux ans alors le
thème de cette conférence et cette année
la régulation des plateformes en ligne
pourquoi est-ce que c'est un enjeu
majeur c'est une nouvelle frontière pour
la régulation tous les pays sont
assaillis par la place d'une part et les
excès qu'on peut observer sur les
réseaux sociaux et donc tous les États
sont à la recherche d'une régulation
qu'on puisse apporter à ces outils qui
sont des outils aussi formidables de
liberté il faut il faut le dire et c'est
vrai que le continent européen et de ce
point de vue là un peu pionnier puisque
l'Union européenne se donne d'un nouveau
règlement qui à partir de l'année
prochaine aux grands acteurs du
numérique ce qu'on appelle le DSA et
donc cette réunion va être l'occasion de
partager nos expériences et de voir
collectivement ensemble avec les valeurs
qui sont celles de la Francophonie
comment on peut mieux réguler ces grands
acteurs de l'Internet alors votre
objectif c'est de garantir le respect
des droits et des libertés de chacun
comment est-ce qu'on fait par quel bout
est-ce qu'on commence quand on voit
l'immensité de la tâche les faux sites
les fake news les infox et qui pullulent
partout sur les réseaux sociaux
un nouveau modèle de régulation qui est
un peu différent de celui qui s'applique
aux médias audiovisuel traditionnel la
régulation des télévisions des radios
est très ancienne maintenant elle est
très rodée j'allais dire là il faut
imaginer autre chose puisque c'est des
centaines de millions d'informations qui
à chaque seconde sont véhicule est pas
c'est par ces plateformes et donc le
principe c'est d'imposer à ces acteurs
des obligations de moyens on leur impose
de lutter contre les contenus illicits
de façon générale y compris en ligne
bien sûr la désin et on s'attache
ensuite à contrôler la façon dont ils
mettent en oeuvre ses moyens et ce
règlement que j'évoquais le DSA
justement confiera à la Commission
européenne avec les régulateurs
nationaux cette mission de contrôle
extérieur et donnera la commission aussi
un pouvoir de sanction important 6% du
chiffre du chiffre d'affaires mondial et
c'est vraiment pas un contrôle de
contenu individuel contenu les uns après
les autres c'est pas chaque tweet ou
chaque message sur facebook on va
chercher c'est de voir si ces
plateformes mettent bien en œuvre les
moyens pour éliminer les contenus
illicites je parlais des fake news des
fake news des infoges quand on voit ce
qui ce qui se passe notamment en Afrique
en ce moment la désinformation qui
circule par exemple on l'a vu ce
week-end avec le coup d'État au Burkina
Faso la France qui est prise à partie la
réussite est mise en avant et est-ce
qu'il y a des solutions pour freiner
justement cette haine sur les réseaux
sociaux on imagine d'ailleurs que c'est
un sujet dont vous allez parler lors de
cette conférence notre conférence avec
des grands témoins qui seront présents
Thierry Breton fera un message en début
on a beaucoup de personnalités qui vont
venir on a les plateformes elles-mêmes
mettant Twitter Google qui seront
présents pour partager avec nos amis
notamment africains parce que l'une des
difficultés aussi des états c'est la
question des interlocuteurs c'est qu'on
a pas toujours en phase de soi un
interlocuteur dans ses plateformes qui
on peut on peut changer et donc voilà
c'est le but c'est de partager nos
expériences nos regards pour ce qui est
du continent européen de faire valoir
les dispositifs qui vont se déployer à
partir de l'année prochaine et c'est
vrai que pour le continent africain
c'est un enjeu un enjeu majeur la
téléphonie très répandue en Afrique
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux et
notamment de facebook extrêmement
répandu et c'est effectivement une terre
de manipulation d'informations on le
voit bien avec des conséquences
diplomatiques en termes de défense et de
déstabilisation souvent pour la vie
politique donc tous ces états ont
vraiment à cœur comme nous-mêmes
d'essayer de trouver les bons les bons
remèdes tout en respectant la liberté
d'expression parce qu'il faut toujours
être dans cette balance
c'est comme pour les médias audiovisuels
la régulation que l'arcom hier le CSA
porte elle est toujours dans cette
balance protéger la liberté c'est notre
première mission et en même temps
veiller à ce que les limites qui ont été
posées par la loi ne soient pas
franchies et quand elles le sont pouvant
intervenir et sanctionner donc là c'est
un enjeu assez exaltant c'est d'imaginer
cette nouvelle régulation c'est nouvelle
frontières de la régulation respectueuse
de nos valeurs nos valeurs de liberté
vous savez que dans la francophonie
c'est des principes qui sont très
importants c'est une entité la
Francophonie qui est très attachée à la
préservation de la paix des droits de
l'homme donc préserver cette liberté et
en même temps mieux répondre aux
attentes des opinions publiques une
meilleure protection des publics
justement vous parlez des publics je
vais parler du jeunes publics avec les
sites pornographiques je rappelle à
noter les spectateurs pour que ce soit
clair que depuis la loi du 30 juillet
2020 l'art comme a le pouvoir d'adresser
une injonction pour ensuite demander à
la justice le blocage d'un site
pornographique si elle constate qu'il
est accessible
hors début septembre la justice vous a
en juin à entamer une médiation avec les
principaux sites pornographiques
l'objectif c'est de trouver un moyen
pour empêcher leurs accès aux mineurs
alors où est-ce que vous en êtes écoutez
l'enjeu est simple la loi vous l'avez
dit donc elle a pour but de protéger les
mineurs il s'agit pas d'interdire la
pornographie il s'agit de veiller à la
protection des mineurs il y a beaucoup
de constats qui ont été faits sur les
conséquences qui peuvent être très
problématiques de l'accès des très
jeunes assez contenus de mineurs sur
trois de moins de 15 ans ont déjà eu
accès des images pornographiques en
ligne selon le rapport du Sénat qui est
exactement
début octobre 2022 et depuis deux ans
depuis que cette loi est entrée en
vigueur les sites n'ont pris aucune
initiative pour se conformer à la loi
donc l'arcom a rempli la mission que le
législateur lui a confié on a mis en
demeure C6 n'ont rien fait on a donc
saisi la justice la justice vient de
décider une procédure de médiation pour
voir avec les sites comment on peut
essayer de construire quelque chose on
va jouer le jeu de la médiation
toutes les semaines qui viennent des
échanges vont avoir lieu j'espère qu'on
pourra trouver un terrain d'entente
c'est un enjeu de société qui est bien
évidemment très très important et
vraiment j'espère que cette médiation va
pouvoir aboutir le Sénat dans son
rapport qui est paru je disais il y a
quelques jours là porno l'enfer du décor
elle dit que la com n'est pas en
capacité de faire son travail et
recommande de renforcer vos prérogatives
vous en pensez quoi je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas tort il faut regarder qui on
est en face de soi il y a eu beaucoup
d'enquêtes qui ont été faites la justice
est d'ailleurs maintenant saisie
d'affaires pénale on voit bien qu'on a
affaire à une véritable industrie et
nous sur la mise en oeuvre de cette loi
sur les violences conjugales de 2020 on
le voit bien c'est des sites qui ont les
meilleurs avocats de la place qui font
feu de tout bois qui comptent chaque
acte qui est pris pour mettre en oeuvre
cette disposition législative ils ont
présenté une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité pour contester même
le texte de loi lui-même et la
contestation va devoir se prononcer sur
ce texte donc je pense si on n'a pas à
un moment un dispositif contraignant il
ne se passera rien et le rapport du
Sénat que vous évoquez la très justement
souligné alors vous expliquer vous vous
bien sûr l'arcom c'est beaucoup de
choses c'est aussi réguler la place des
femmes dans l'audiovisuel la place des
personnes atteintes de handicap il y a
aussi toute cette régulation faite par
rapport au site au contenu sportif j'en
viens à ces contenus sportifs environ
806 de diffusion ici de continuer
sportifs depuis janvier 2022 ont été
bloqués sachant que la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar arrive j'imagine vous allez
redoubler de vigilance
à souligner que ce que nous faisons en
réalité est au service des Françaises et
des Français on s'assure du bon
fonctionnement du paysage audiovisuel
radio funny de plus en plus des réseaux
sociaux c'est au service des Français à
la fois pour leur offrir une information
libre bien évidemment on est là d'abord
pour défendre la liberté de
communication la liberté éditoriale on
est très vigilant sur ce point là et en
même temps d'assurer une meilleure
protection des publics et c'est vrai que
la lutte contre le piratage c'est c'est
un gros enjeu le piratage ça
représentait une moins value d'un peu
plus d'un milliard d'euros l'année
dernière donc c'est des sommes
considérables et la loi donc à
l'occasion de la création de l'arcom au
1er janvier nous a donné de nouveaux
outils qui sont révèle très efficaces
notamment sur le piratage sportif
puisqu'on peut intervenir extrêmement
rapidement dans le blocage des sites
illicits puisque le piratage maintenant
se fait par le biais du streaming et
donc vous l'avez dit depuis le 1er
janvier donc sur un peu plus d'un
semestre on a bloqué plus de 800 sites
donc oui on est très vigilant et surtout
on est dans une phase où on automatise
nos procédures entre les ayants droites
ces manifestations les fournisseurs
d'accès qui peuvent bloquer les sites
illicites et nous-mêmes donc voilà c'est
une chaîne un peu continue et quasi
automatisée qui va nous permettre d'agir
très rapidement un dernier mot très très
rapidement parce qu'on doit on doit se
quitter la place des femmes on en est où
en France là au niveau des médias quand
j'ai pris mes fonctions essentiel
l'égalité entre les femmes est un
principe fondamental et il faut que les
médias soient exemplaires en la matière
les médias doivent refléter la société
aujourd'hui plus que normale que les
femmes et toutes leurs places dans les
médias on n'est pas très loin de la
parité vous avez une belle illustration
encore un petit effort voilà donc on ne
lâchera pas merci beaucoup aux Olivier
Mestre d'avoir été avec nous et puis on
vous souhaite plein de courage pour
cette journée cette conférence du
réframe qui débute donc aujourd'hui à
l'Unesco merci beaucoup merci beaucoup